ADAM LEONARD: Hello my name is
Adam Leonard from the People
Development within Google here.
And I'm really excited about
introducing my friend, Daniel
Rechtschaffen
today for the talk.
And in particular, as one of
the founders of gPause, which
is Google's global meditation
community of practitioners,
one of the things that
inspires me the most
is the ripple effects that this
practice has through society,
becoming more mindful.
And Daniel talk today
about the ripple effects
within the educational
system and children.
So let me give you a little
bit about his background
and then I'll turned
over to Daniel.
So Daniel's a marriage
and family therapist
here in the Bay
Area and the author
of the book "The Way
of Mindful Education:
Cultivating Well-Being in
Teachers and Students."
And we have copies of the
book over here after the talk.
And so Daniel leads mindful
and education trainings,
both at conferences
around the world,
in addition to several different
educational institutions.
He also teaches mindfulness
to high school basketball
and baseball teams, which
I thought was interesting.
So let me turn it
over to Daniel.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL RECHTSCHAFFEN:
Hello, everybody.
I've been teaching mostly in
an elementary school recently,
so you all look rather big
to me and a little serious.
So I figured I'd
start off by bringing
in a little bit of
levity and playfulness.
With little kids, you
need to play mindfulness.
You need to-- instead
of paying attention,
you need to be
playing attention.
If I'm trying to go
in and teaching kids
how to focus and to
regulate their emotions,
it's going to become
really boring, really fast.
And it's going to feel
like that old game
where your parents say, let's
see who can be quiet longest.
And kids know really quick,
that's no kind of game.
And they'll, this doesn't
sound like a game.
So let's do a little
bit of movement.
I always start with
some movement with kids,
because I see some people have
some food so you might just,
for a little moment,
put with the food down.
We'll just do a few
little movements
to get us more present and
relaxed here in our bodies.
And often when I teach, I tell
people, especially teachers--
I train a lot of teachers.
And I say, we're going
to-- let's pretend
to be kids for a minute.
And when you say that
to teachers and adults,
they're even worse
than little kids.
You'll get like a spit ball
immediately in the eye.
So, be your adult self,
but let's do some movement.
So let's start with a
few Spiderman breaths.
So let's breathe in, and breathe
out and shoot out your webs.
[EXHALES] [INHALES]
[EXHALES] [INHALES] [EXHALES]
And how about some
dolphin breaths.
[INHALES] [EXHALES] [INHALES]
[EXHALES] [INHALES] [EXHALES]
And some crocodile breaths.
[INHALES] [EXHALES] [INHALES]
[EXHALES] [INHALES] [EXHALES]
And a few butterfly breaths.
[EXHALES] [EXHALES] [EXHALES]
And how about a couple, I've
been working a few hours
and I'm really
stressed, breaths.
So lift up your
shoulders, tighten them,
breathe out and relax.
Ah.
Let's do a few of those.
[INHALES] [EXHALES] [INHALES]
[EXHALES]
And then see if you can just
be as still as a statue.
And notice as you breathe,
if any parts of your body
are moving.
Even though you're
trying to be still,
see where the movement
in your body is.
Thank you for playing
attention with me.
Very often, for
adults and for kids,
it's really easy--
like if I came in here
and said, let's learn
some mindfulness
and practice for 30
minutes, a lot of you
would start to
equate mindfulness
with this profoundly
frustrating experience.
And our brains would
actually link that up, right?
Link up?
And that's probably
why when we like,
oh, I should really
practice mindfulness
this morning, everything in
our bodies kind of yells,
don't do it.
It's so annoying.
It's because very often
when we try to do it,
we do it outside of our range.
And so for kids, the range might
be five seconds or 10 seconds.
And so for me to do these fun
movements, then as you saw,
I progressively got
a little bit smaller,
until I did this very
fun, accessible, ah,
see what happens when
you are breathing,
feeling the movement.
And immediately, kids
will come back and say,
I think I felt my heart beating.
Or I can feel my hips going
in and out like a balloon
as I was breathing.
You'll get these
fascinating inner awareness
that's being cultivated.
And you don't have to be top
heavy with it, telling them OK,
now you're going to
have to be still.
OK, Joey, stop moving.
OK, Sally, you know.
And you really just
invite them into this fun
inner exploration.
So I wanted to begin and give a
little overview of mindfulness
in education and
how it's spreading.
One of organizations
that I really
love that's doing
some amazing work
is an organization called
The Holistic Life Foundation
and they're in Baltimore.
They're good buddies of mine.
And just to show what they've
been doing in the Baltimore
schools, and they have
all of these things
in the different school
settings where they'll
have a mindfulness room.
And the mindfulness
room will always
be having this kind
of soothing music.
They even have these
like essential oil blends
that are putting out nice scents
The room is just
a space for them
to be able-- for the
students to be able to come.
So, when they've had a fight,
when there's a conflict,
teachers won't send the
kids to the principal.
They'll send them to
the mindfulness room.
And in the mindfulness room,
the kids aren't like punished.
What have you done?
They're invited just
to be present and talk
about what's going on.
And so, during all of the
conflict and difficulty that's
been happening in Baltimore,
every day The Holistic Life
Foundation, Ali and Atman
Smith and Andy Gonzales,
they've been doing these
mindfulness days in the park.
So while the city
was burning, they
were getting people
together to be
able to meditate on what those
really difficult emotions that
are rising in their
bodies are about
and having these
amazing conversations.
They have trained-- they're
all from inner city Baltimore
and have trained all
of their facilitators
are these young kids who
come through their program.
And now they've
given them jobs to go
into all of these
other Baltimore schools
to be able to be teaching
how to regulate emotion,
how to be able to develop
executive functioning.
How to be able to
cultivate empathy.
There's all this
really amazing research
that's been around for a
while, but for some reason,
it hasn't been
disseminated as widely
as it should in terms of social
and cultural diversity work.
There's an amazing study
called The Ace Study.
I don't know if any of you
know about The Ace Study,
where it's for the Adverse
Childhood Experiences test.
And it talks about the different
traumas or major stresses
that people have
had in their life.
So if you've had adverse
experiences, whether that's
a real kind of capital
T trauma, like some type
of physical or sexual
abuse, or even just living
in an environment
that's very stressful,
even that's often in
the schools around
here, where there's
this incredible push
and stress for kids to achieve.
So if you're growing up
with all of these stressors,
I'll just read a few of the
things that it predicts.
So one of the first
amazing things
is, if you have a lot of
these very intense stressors,
traumas, your life
expectancy is 20 years less,
which is rather amazing.
People with high ACE
scores are three times as
likely to experience
academic failure,
six times as likely to have
behavioral problems, and five
times as likely to have
attendance problems.
So we set up kids in a very
disturbing environment,
and their brain architecture
that we're really
finding that the architecture
of the brain, even the genetics,
is changed by stress levels.
Even more amazingly,
more recent research
is finding that the
levels of stress
can change the genetics which
gets passed on to their kids.
So there's these high
levels of trauma and stress,
whether that's-- I work a lot
in-- one day I'll be in like
a Berkeley, very
privileged school,
and I'll see the intent
stressors that these kids are
under to achieve.
And then the next day, I'll
be in an inner city Oakland
school, with very different
types of stressors,
but all stressors.
And this stress physically
affects the body
and really hijacks the mind
to be able to be present
and to think and to be creative.
So all of the
testing that we throw
on our kids, all of this really
intense high stakes testing,
actually dumbs the mind down.
It puts people in even
more of a kind of fight
or flight or a freeze response.
So, such a big part of
the mindfulness training,
that I do, the emotional
intelligence training,
is first, how do
we get kids to feel
comfortable and relaxed and
present in their bodies.
So one of the big things I've
also been tracking recently,
is you probably also
the news around New York
and a lot of the other states
that opted out of tests.
So 175,000 students
in New York opted out
of the standardized testing.
In some places it was 70% of
the entire school district,
the kids said, we're
not taking these tests.
So there's a big shift
happening in education.
I recently had somebody
from Silicon Valley who's
trying to start a school,
and he came to me and said,
I want to create this school.
I consult with a lot
of different schools,
bringing in mindfulness
and emotional intelligence
around the world.
But what was particularly
amazing for me
about what this
gentleman was bringing
was that he was
saying, that they're
going to bring a lot of
what you all at Google
are developing
amazingly, they're
bringing all of the tech in
information, kind of Khan
Academy style information.
So all the information
that's going to be delivered
is going to be from the great
scientists and professors
from the great institutions
around the world.
And what that does is,
it completely frees up
the teachers.
They're no longer
information purveyors.
And what they are becoming
now in this school
that I'm consulting with,
what they are going to become
is emotional
intelligence, mindfulness,
kind of helping the kids
find meaning, helping
them be creative, helping
them find their path in life.
Helping them understand how to
access knowledge, helping them
understand to be their
best people, which
is an amazing shift.
Because so many teachers
that I talk with,
tell me that about
half of their time
anyway is basically
as a social worker,
trying to get their kids
to stop moving around.
They have so much ADHD.
There's so much disregulation.
I could explain the numbers
of the anxiety and depression
that's like going through
the roof with kids
as young as like kindergarten.
Kids are getting diagnoses at
these incredibly young ages.
So for the teachers
to actually be there
as these holistic
support systems,
and then to be able to give
them all of this information
that's readily accessible.
So what I want to do is to
walk through what mindfulness
and what's called social,
emotional learning, some fun
ways that it's offered, and
what it actually can do.
So there's five
different realms that I
look at of different
types of literacy,
not just what Common
Core does, which
is just kind of
math and language,
but five deeper
realms of literacy.
Which are the literacy
of our bodies,
the literacy of our minds,
literacy of our hearts,
literacy around
the social world,
and then literacy around
kind of our ecology,
our understanding of our
place in nature and the world.
So we can start with the
literacy of our bodies.
I just did a little bit
with you around just
those Spiderman breaths.
That's us learning how
to be in touch, relaxed,
connected to our bodies.
Adam was telling
me before about how
he does some work with veterans
who are returning from war.
He said he starts by doing
these great like rafting trips
and fun things with them,
getting them in their body
and teaching them about
mindfulness through getting
into the flow, getting
connected to what's alive
all around them.
So there's all these
different access points.
So I start with
kids, if their minds
are hijacked, which
so many of them
are, how do we help them drop
into their bodies to integrate?
So the first thing--
and I'll walk us
all through some exercises
to be experiential.
If everybody just
puts up one hand.
And why don't we look
at it for a moment,
just kind of explore this hand
that's always typing and doing
everything for you.
But you probably
haven't actually
taken a look at all the
little lines and colors in it.
And then you could
let your eyes close.
And since your eyes
are closed, how
do you know that
your hand is there?
What are the physical sensations
that you can feel in there?
And maybe why don't you
feel the other hand,
see what's sensations
are in the other hand.
Are they different?
Are they the same?
The fingers, the palm, see if
you can get really interested.
And how about feeling both
hands at the same time?
OK.
Thank you for
playing that with me.
So, often with kids
what I'll do is
a really give them a language
for their physical experience.
We'll go through
our bodies, maybe
we'll pick something
up and do, you
know, write with a
pencil in slow motion,
feeling the way the
hand moves, doing
different types of
slow motion movements,
really learning the sensations.
I'll go up on the blackboard
and have kids say,
what you feel in your body.
And I'll show you as we go
through the mind, the heart,
why we need to start with this
kind of physical literacy,
understanding how the
body feels, how it moves,
what it means to be relaxed,
what it means to be stressed.
Teaching kids where stress is
in the body and what it feels
like.
So really giving them this
language of the physical body.
Then I move on, once the kids
are relaxed, they're present,
I move on to some mind training.
So teaching them how to,
what we talk a lot about,
as building the
muscles of attention.
And there's something about
this attention practice
that I'm sure all of
you-- and still in schools
I hear over and
over again, teachers
yelling at kids to pay attention
or not to be distracted.
But we don't teach them
how to pay attention
or how not to get
distracted or how
to be calm, how to be
relaxed in their body.
So there's really
precise, clear ways
to develop this
sense of attention.
One of the ways that kids seem
to really love exploring it
is a game that I call
the distraction game.
So I'll go into a classroom
and I'll teach kids
how to take their hands and
put them on their bellies
and just to feel their
breath moving in and out.
And then what I'll do
is, I will walk around,
and usually most
schools I'm in, there's
lots of like pencil
jars and things
you can make noises with.
And I'll say, who thinks they
can be totally focused, even
if I try to distract them?
And kids really like this, and
so they'll put up their hands.
And I'll go around
and I'll start
making noises and
opening the door
and jumping around
and being silly.
And they're really trying
to keep their focus
on their breath.
I call it the base camp breath.
And have them really
stay right there.
And the kids are so
interested in it,
and then a bunch of the other
kids will say, can I try that?
I'm like, OK, let's all do it.
And then eventually, I'll
ask for some distractor's
assistants.
And so usually
pretty much always,
I'll choose the kids who are the
most distracting, the ones that
are always distracting
the rest of the class.
And I'll let them get up and
kind of walk around the room,
making noise and rattling things
and trying to distract kids.
And I'll explore in real
time, the dynamics that
are happening in the classroom.
So, asking them,
what was it like?
What does it feel
like in your body
when you so want to open your
eyes or you so want to giggle?
Kids will try to go--
I'll be like, OK, Yeah,
if you want you can
try to tell some jokes
and get kids to laugh.
See what it's like to
try to stay regulated.
So they are actually
practicing regulation.
They're really working with
integrating their brains so
that they can keep this
kind of sense of integration
and calming their
amygdala down so
that they can have
more executive
functioning in their brains.
And we can really talk
to them about this.
If they're little kids, you
can talk to them what about,
like the lizard brain,
which captures the top part
of your brain, the neocortex.
And how we can let
the lizard relax
by doing these breaths
and then the mind
and can work in
a more sharp way.
Once I do that, we can actually
teach kids and definitely
high school students,
middle school students,
but even really young children
can start learning how,
not just to be aware
of distraction,
of kind of externals, but
how they're distracted
by their own thoughts.
How their own mental
constructions,
whether those are kind
of destructive thoughts
about themselves or
whether they're just
random thoughts about the
movie they want to go see.
And then-- well, let's all
put our hands on our belly
for another second.
And what we can do is, you
can let your eyes close.
And what we can explore is
just anchoring our attention
in the breath.
So you're feeling your breath
going in and out of your belly.
And what you could
notice is, any time
a thought pops into
your head, our brains
are kind of like popcorn makers.
But instead of making thoughts
or instead of making popcorn,
they make thoughts.
Any time a thought goes
through your head, just
pop your hand up.
And just kind of lift it up in
the air and then bring it back.
And when you're bringing
your hand back to your belly,
you're bringing
your attention back
to the breath the physical
sensation of the belly,
like a balloon getting
bigger and smaller.
And anytime the mind
pops with a thought--
and if you're wondering,
if you're thinking
that's a thought itself.
--you can always just
pop it in the air,
collect yourself, and bring
the hand back to the belly.
So let's try that for a minute.
It's amazing to watch
and listen to what
students say about this.
So you'll get like a
second grade class,
so young children,
who really start
witnessing how their own
minds are hijacking them,
and how they're building
these muscles of attention,
learning how to stay--
like a kid the other day
said, like always when I'm
reading, I'll be reading
and my eyes will go down
to the bottom of the page.
And then I'll realize
that I've gotten
to the bottom of the page,
but I wasn't actually taking
in the words.
And I'm trying to build
my muscles of attention,
so that I can actually read
it and then finish it and then
play some baseball or
something like that.
So they really
understand this capacity
to keep the attention focused.
So once I've developed
these muscles of attention,
awareness of our minds,
awareness of our bodies,
then we move on to the emotions.
And so, there's this
really profound way
that we bring the
body and the attention
together for basic
impulse control,
basic emotional regulation.
So we talk to kids
all the time about,
don't steal the cookie
from the cookie jar.
Don't hit your brother.
Don't do these
things, don't react.
We look at a place
like Baltimore,
and say, don't do that.
Don't destroy this
building in your own city.
But when there's
so much emotion,
when there's so much hurt, when
there's so much difficulty,
we haven't really taught kids
what to do with that emotion.
And so it needs to spill over.
So it doesn't really make
sense to punish them.
Usually punishing in
the way we often punish,
really just adds more
kind of fire to it.
So what we do is, I
usually explain to kids,
like I imagine that
my arm is a branch.
And it's going up, and up
here all of these leaves,
they're kind of
like my thoughts.
And so anytime
there's a lot of wind
and the branch is
going like this,
it's kind of like
I'm ruminating.
I'm thinking about
something a lot.
I'm like churning about this
argument I had with my wife.
Or I'm churning about this
thing that my boss said.
And so any time there's that
hamster wheel of thinking,
there's always a correlation.
So if you follow the
branch down into your body
and check out in your throat,
in your chest, in your stomach,
somewhere in your body there's
always a physical correlation
of how you actually
physically feel
to that ruminating thought.
And usually what we do
when we're ruminating,
when we're really
caught in something,
is usually we think
like, oh, man,
I can't believe she said that.
What should I say next time?
Maybe I'll do this.
And that just pushes
the hamster wheel more.
And you all know this, I'm sure.
This is why we can't
fall asleep at night
sometimes is, the mind is just
working, working, working,
working.
And we think then maybe
I'll be able to fix it
by thinking our way
out of it, which
is-- if anybody's ever thought
their way out of something
like that, let me know.
Because usually even if we
come up with a great thought,
then we have to--
oh, would that work?
How can I do that?
So what we can do, really
the only place that there's
some type of soothing
and relaxation,
is if we drop down
into our bodies
and locate where the
physical experience is.
So if the thought about
like this argument is there,
there's probably
some like agitation,
heat in the chest,
tightness in the belly,
maybe the face is
a little tight.
And so with kids, once
you've taught them
the physical capacity,
the physical literacy,
they'll be able
to find, oh, yeah,
there's this heat right here.
There's this
agitation right here.
There's this discomfort.
And then I do a lot of what I
call the vacuum cleaner breath,
where they suck in all of
this uncomfortable energy
into their belly,
they relax it, really
becoming aware of the
physical experience,
and that is where-- what
mindfulness basically is,
is when we orient into, towards
the present moment, what's
happening right now.
We open to what's
happening right now instead
of pushing away from
it into our brains,
trying to think, how can
we fix this or change this.
So it's a very simple
orientation shift.
And it's a little bit
opposite, counterintuitive,
that if you orient
into pain or orient
into agitation, when we
bring our kind of openness,
our heartfulness,
it actually relaxes.
It soothes.
That's most of the research in
the beginning of mindfulness.
Mindfulness-based
stress reduction
was about chronic pain.
And if you actually
bring your attention
into a chronic back
pain, it actually
relaxes instead of
tightening against it,
which adds more pain.
So with kids, I do these
very basic explanations.
Maybe I'll have them
picture somebody
that they're annoyed with.
And they'll picture
them, and then you
can actually feel,
physically, what that's like.
And then to actually feel it
and to breathe and to relax.
And instead of-- very
often I'll hear in schools,
even schools that don't
teach mindfulness,
they'll say take three deep
breaths when you're angry.
But usually when kids
do that, they just
go, [QUICK BREATHS] and then
they just go right back to it,
right, instead of
really getting like, OK,
so when I actually
notice that I'm agitated,
and they can catch it.
Oh, there it is.
OK, there's tightness.
There's a little
bit of butterflies.
OK, I'm present with
it, breathing with it,
I'm noticing it,
I'm relaxing it.
And when we do that and we
reinforce it over and over
again, it's life changing.
There's all of this research
around impulse control as one
of the major
predictors around who
will go to prison, how
well people are going
to do on tests, how successful
academically they'll be,
just by their early
capacity to be able to be
present with their impulses.
So with the emotional
work, both we're
learning to work with
the intense emotions
and then we're also learning
to cultivate the more
kind of beneficial, sweet
compassion, empathy, joy,
happiness, all of these
beautiful practices
that we can do around gratitude.
Often I'll have people bring in
a kind of a picture of somebody
that for them, it is the
most compassionate person
in their minds or their
hearts, whether it's
one of their grandparents or
whether it's Mother Teresa.
And to picture them
and then to really
bring in that energy to
start actually bringing
that compassion into the world.
So students learn how to work
with the difficult emotion,
to cultivate the empathy.
Then the fourth piece
that I like to do
is more of the
social, cultural work.
And right now, one of
the things I'm really
fascinated about
with this is what's
happening in Baltimore, what's
happening around our country
and has been for a long
time around diversity,
around how we have so much
assumptions about racism,
and how we can actually teach
kids to open their minds up,
to develop empathy in a
very-- in a physical way.
And when I say
physical, often it's
very easy to go in
and tell people,
you should be nice to each
other, you should do this.
That doesn't really
help most of the time.
It feels like another should.
But when we can teach kids to
really feel in their bodies.
One practice I've
been doing recently
is I'll put like an
object up on a table
and I'll have everybody just
look at this one object.
And just kind of have a
mindfulness practice on it
for a minute or so.
And just looking at it, and
just since we've already
been doing a lot of these
attention practices,
have them just have this
relaxed mind, breathing.
And just seeing,
as they're looking
at it, what assumptions
come up about this object.
Noticing if they really
like it, if they dislike it,
if they have a judgment,
if they have a correlation.
And amazingly, even if you like
just put a bottle or a book,
afterwards, the whole
class is going to fill in.
I really like- I got so
annoyed looking at that book.
I loved that book.
I have this assumption
because my brother like
hit me with a book one time.
And you're going to get
all of the stuff in there.
And teaching kids the ways
that we develop assumptions
and then helping them
understand how we all
have that towards each other,
how we put each other in boxes.
And how mindfulness
can actually help
us see each other in this much
more clear and conscious way.
So another one of
the main practices
that I do-- and I'm going
to wrap up in a few minutes
because I want to be
able to really open
some conversation
for all of you.
One of the other practices
that I love to do
is around the present moment.
And so teaching kids, I'll
ask a lot of questions
about what is the past.
And they'll explain
what happened you know,
the dinosaurs and that they
tripped on the way to school
this morning and all these
things that happened.
And then what's in
the future, there's
going to be-- we're
going to be on Mars,
or that my birthday is on
Sunday or whatever it is.
And then asking
them what is right
now in the present moment?
And I'll teach kids to be able
to communicate with each other
from just what's happening
in the present moment, which
is a very fascinating
practice if anybody has ever
really tried to do this.
To have a conversation back
and forth where the rules are.
The only thing you
can say is, my back is
hurting a little bit right now.
The lights are a little
heavy in my eyes.
I'm feeling my voice in
my larynx as I'm talking.
So actually to be able to
really just speak present moment
and seeing what happens to
people when you take away
all story and learn how to
communicate in this very
empathic present moment way.
So the practices are really
learning this landscape
of empathy of communication.
And then the final stage
is more of this kind
of ecological awareness,
which obviously right now is
so important, understanding how
we are connected to everything.
We do a lot of work bringing--
I love bringing kids out
into nature.
And for me, there's no better
teacher than the natural world.
If you want to learn
patience, you sit by a tree.
You do something like that.
And so really starting to
learn and ask questions
to kids about their
environment, about how they're
connected to their environment.
So I just wanted to
walk through these five
main realms of literacy.
That in schools around the US,
Canada, all over the world,
whole school
districts are starting
to learn how to integrate
this level of kind
of critical thinking
and awareness
so that kids can really
master their own minds
and then can go out into
the world in this much more
empowered way.
In this work that's
been happening
around a big transformation
in education,
there's a bit of a
revolutionary piece to it.
Because there's a
lot of-- I don't
know if you know how
the Texas School Board's
kind of curriculum committee is
the one for some reason, that
makes all the decisions
about curriculum, mostly
in the entire country.
Usually the ones
that Texas chooses
is what most of
the schools follow.
And a big part of Texas
Republican platform
came out a couple
years ago saying
that they were opposed to
critical thinking skills,
because they thought that it
was going to-- they thought
that it would undermine values.
And so nothing against
Republicans or specific people,
but that basic concept of
critical thinking skills
and teaching kids how
to think for themselves
and to be creative, the way
that Google here kind of-- some
of the ways that this
organization is set up
for you to have
free thinking, we're
needing that in our
educational paradigm.
And it isn't like
that right now.
It's all very top down.
You know, follow what we say.
Memorization,
information memorization,
not much transformation,
not much change,
not much creativity,
not much openness.
Literal, very clear
pushback about kids
doing these types of
mindfulness practices, which
are going to be a
liberation practice, kind
of a waking up practice
where they're going to learn,
who am I?
What is my body?
What is my mind?
What is my heart?
What is the world around me?
How am I connected
to everything?
So there's a big
transformation that
needs to happen in
our world in order
for the ecological
system, the social system,
for things to be more healthy.
And mindfulness, as a
practice is the exact antidote
that I'm looking to
as a way to help kids
wake up, to help to see better.
So what I would love to do--
we have a bunch of time.
But what I would love to do
is to open this up and just
have some questions
and some dialogue.
We have about 20 minutes
because it's always
a little more interesting to
get some cross pollination.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
way that technology
can help people
to be more mindful
and just create more
like compassionate people
or is it actually taking
people away from that?
DANIEL RECHTSCHAFFEN: I
am so happy it, especially
here at Google.
Do you have an idea?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
I mean, not exactly.
DANIEL RECHTSCHAFFEN: So
there's a lot to this.
So there are some apps that
are coming out that I actually
really appreciate.
Mostly the apps that
I'm appreciating
are apps that are around
empathy and compassion
and mindfulness where
the kids are doing
are doing something
in the app and then
the app has little kind
of assignments for them.
OK, now, go do two random acts
of kindness and then come back.
And you get to this level.
So for me, to learn to
develop emotionally,
you need to do it
interpersonally.
You actually need to be in
contact with others and not
just somebody on the other
side of the computer.
It needs to be--
there's something
about the actual resonant
fields of two bodies,
the mirror neurons that
are actually waking up when
you're across from somebody.
So I think that there's
some amazing stuff
that technology can do.
And obviously just
with all of the work
that's happening where there's
these amazing interconnected
webs where we know
about an Apollo.
All of a sudden, we know about
here, we know about Syria.
And we're able to
hear so much more.
We're able to
develop that empathy.
But on a really basic--
I mean as a therapist,
I work with mostly
adults, but I work
with individuals around what it
really takes to heal and grow
and it takes a lot.
So it's basically down to
like attachment theory, which
means our most core wounds are
around ways that we weren't
loved, ways we weren't met,
ways that we don't really
trust each other.
And in order to
change that, it needs
to be in person, whether it's
a therapist or a community
or a loving relationship,
that's where these-- you know,
your mind can be like,
oh yeah, I trust that.
But the body is still like,
oh, I don't know about that.
So what I would say
is that if technology
is working with in person,
relational support,
it can be amazing.
And at the same time, there's
some great attention trainings
that are online that
work really well.
So if you're just looking
for basic attention training,
there's some great online tools
where you can follow something
or you can get biofeedback
to see how well the breath is
happening.
So attention training, which
is a little different than just
mindfulness.
Attention training
can be trained
in a lot of different ways.
But it is often the metaphor
of like in the military, well
before mindfulness, they
had something called
sniper breath,
which is focusing,
regulating their
breath to this extent
so that they can
shoot really well.
Which is not what I'd
consider mindfulness.
Mindfulness is you need
to weave in this kind
of empathic presence.
So we can train some attention,
but for this larger scale,
like opening the awareness to
the environment, to nature,
to each other, which
we're lacking so much.
There's a research study that
was just done out of UCLA where
they took kids-- one
classroom and brought them
into like a nature
retreat for a week.
So no technology.
Other school just stayed there.
And then they brought them
back and they gave them
some emotional
intelligence tests.
So basically showing
faces, and getting
them to see, oh, that's
a sad face, that's
a happy face, very basic kind
of showing how well can you
recognize others'
emotions, be empathic.
And the kids who'd been
in nature for the week
scored way higher.
But they hadn't
done anything, they
hadn't taught them
anything about emotion.
But just unplugging them
for a week, to let them
just kind drop in.
I don't know why it
did it, but there's
something about getting
them into a little bit
more natural state.
So I'm a major proponent
of using technology
to help kids unplug,
which I don't
know exactly how that works.
But we need that balance.
AUDIENCE: Towards the end, you
talked about the transformation
that you think needs to happen
within the education system.
I'm just wondering,
for places where
you've seen that
start to happen,
what does that look like?
Where within the
system does it start?
What are the sort of
conditions and characteristics
that might need to be in place?
DANIEL RECHTSCHAFFEN:
Thank you so much for that.
So there's actually a
lot that's going on.
So there's mindfulness
itself and then
there's also social
emotional learning.
And there's a great
organization called
Castle, the Collaborative for
Academic, Social and Emotional
Learning, which is in eight
of the major school districts
and has been doing a few years
of really intensive studies
to find out how
really integrating
emotional intelligence into
the whole school systems, how
it works.
It's in Oakland right now, has
been for the last few years.
In these eight districts, the
academic scores went up 11%.
And for anybody
in academics, like
for academic scores to go
up 11% from any intervention
is like staggering.
But the staggering
piece about that
is, they weren't
teaching any academics.
This was purely
emotional support.
So getting the teachers, which
is always important to first.
Train the teachers how to
regulate their emotions
to be present, to focus.
Then training kids how to
be more aware of each other.
So just this kind of relaxing
of nervous systems that
allows them to pay attention.
What I've started-- I
started doing this work
at this organization
called Mindful Schools back
eight or nine years
ago in Oakland.
And what we first were doing was
just going into the classroom
and teaching kids,
which was amazing
because we started seeing like,
wow, this stuff really works.
Kids really are able
to be more empathic.
They're able to pay
attention better.
But what would happen
is, I would teach
and then I thank the
class and I would get out.
And I'd hear the
teacher yelling at them,
get back in your seats.
Like oh, that doesn't
work very well.
It needs to be a
systemic approach.
So what I've done mostly in
the last four or five years
is training teachers.
So I'll go to a
school and I'll do
a lot of professional
development,
a lot of work with them about
burnout and stress for teachers
is huge.
The dropout rate for teachers
is higher than it is for kids.
Like most teachers leave
within three years.
So really teaching
them how to regulate,
how to pay attention to the
kids, how to attune to them.
So there's a lot of school
districts around the country
that are doing this.
The way that it usually
looks depends on the schools.
But there's a lot of really
good emotional intelligence
curriculum.
And the way that
mindfulness usually
works really beautifully,
is that mindfulness
dovetails with all this
emotional intelligence work.
Because as I said
before, if we're
trying to teach kids empathy, we
bring in these basic practices,
which we'll have the
class start every day
with a little breathing.
Start, or have in the middle
of the day, do a little bit
where they're aware
of something that's
triggering or frustrating them
and doing some breath with it.
So kind of throughout the day,
integrating these practices
around emotional
regulation, around focus.
And all different schools are
doing it really creatively.
Some have their
own rooms or a kind
of a corner of the room that's
like what they call a peace
corner, where if the kids
are really stirred up,
they self-M refer
themselves there,
instead of the
teachers telling them.
So they start learning
this inner resilience,
this inner capacity, so that
they don't need to be punished.
But they can say, oh wow,
there's a lot going on in me.
I need to go sit over here for
minute and regulate myself.
So it looks a lot
of different ways.
One of the major ways one
of the main things that I do
is, I have a book,
my book, and then
I have a book that
I'm about to publish,
which is really a curriculum.
And so there's a
lot of schools that
are using mindfulness-based
curricula in training
their teachers.
That's really the best
way is if you really
get the teachers trained
in their own practice.
And then have some
kind of workbooks
that they can use
with the kids, rather
than me having to go
around the country teaching
little lessons or
something, really getting
the-- One of my major
long term visions
would be how we could get this
type of foundational training
into every teacher in college.
So how could every
teacher learn about how
to work with their stress
and the stress of their kids.
AUDIENCE: You go up a
level with teachers.
Is it ever necessary
go further up
and work with
administrators, et cetera.
Do teachers then run into
issues with administrators
who are feeling the pressure
to get test scores up?
And also what kind
of resistance--
do you ever get resistance
from the adults in general
when you're trying
to teach this?
DANIEL RECHTSCHAFFEN:
So let's take the two
really important ones.
So first one is, sometimes
you get really lucky
and you have an
administrator who's already
into mindfulness or something.
And of course, that's great.
This needs to be systemic,
because the stress is
everywhere.
It's important to look around.
It's easy to point fingers
and think like, oh,
that person is the evil person
who's making this all-- but
everybody's under this stress.
So actually I have a
group of 30 administrators
that I've been doing monthly
calls with for the last year,
talking with them about
how to integrate this
into their schools.
So it's so important, if you
have an administrator shifting
the environment
for the teachers--
and this is why it's more
impact when I teach teachers.
It's more impact when
I teach administrators.
Because obviously if
they're able to create
a more empathic and
relaxed state, environment,
that's huge.
So yeah, it needs
to go in everywhere.
I mean it needs to-- there's
one of our congressman, Ohio
Congressman Tim Ryan, actually
has a mindfulness sitting group
and that he does in
Congress. [INAUDIBLE]
I talked to him because he
came to a conference I lead.
He was like, we had
three people last time.
That was the most
people we've had.
But we're getting more.
It's getting more.
So we need to spread
this everywhere.
In terms of
resistance, mindfulness
is an introspective practice.
So you can't force somebody
to be introspective.
Because being introspective
is vulnerable.
To look inside, if you lived
your life really fast and doing
and doing and doing, when you
slow down, you're like, wow,
there's a lot going on in there.
So you can't force
somebody to do that.
It's, by its nature-- if
a kid's sitting there,
I have no idea what's
going on their mind.
going on in your mind.
You might have been checked
out this entire talk.
I don't know what's
happening inside your brains.
So all we can do is
invite you to the feast
of these practices.
And so, I always
get some resistance
from some people who
don't really want it.
And I never push.
I never push kids.
I never push parents or
teachers or administrators.
One of the things that
does come up and often
is asked, is around the
history of mindfulness
and it's Buddhist aspects and
if there's resistance there.
Because there actually has been
at least one that I know of,
school that got in
trouble with the courts
because they were
doing what they thought
was Buddhist practice.
And there's a lot to that.
For me, I mean I'm
not a Buddhist.
A lot of these
practices were developed
in a Buddhist tradition.
But for me.
It's much wider than
a Buddhist tradition.
This is about-- I mean I
haven't used a word yet,
I hope, that seems religious.
We're talking about how
to be good human beings.
And I'm happy to bring from
any tradition or anyplace,
some type of practice which
doesn't have any-- which
won't turn anybody into
a specific religion,
but that's going to help people.
So people are afraid of that.
Usually what I do is
I'll invite people
to the training or to
watch the kids doing it.
And pretty much always, they're
like, I could use this as well.
There was just a
big court judgment
down in LA Unified Schools,
where there was a yoga program
and they were trying
to get it kicked out.
And the judge ruled
against, and said, yes, this
seems like it comes
from a Hindu tradition.
But it doesn't have
any spiritual words
or spiritual aims.
It's just movement
and breathing.
So I actually think that that's
probably, in years to come,
as mindfulness gets
huge, there might
be some court cases that
are going to be coming up
on a larger scale.
And for me, as I said
with the Texas Republican
platform, who said we don't
want to teach critical thinking
skills.
There's both a
resistance to kind,
of is this religion,
which I think
is a really good question.
We don't want to teach
religion in schools.
But there's also a question
about what mindfulness truly
is, which is a
self-inquiry practice.
And we're teaching
kids to question.
And a lot of people in
schools are afraid of that.
For me personally, there's a
lot about the school system
that I question.
And if people really
inquired deeply,
they would actually kind
of rip it up at the seams
and transform it.
So a lot of people I
think, and for good reason,
are kind of afraid of a
deep inquiry practice, both
because they don't want to
look inside of themselves,
and they don't really want
to look at the system that's
out of balance.
AUDIENCE: It's
really interesting
hearing about you are
working with young kids.
I was wondering if we can
take a step even before that
and wonder what can, for
instance parents of very
young children, like toddlers,
preschoolers do to kind of work
with them and kind of
get them in to a mode
where they're receptive
to mindfulness as they're
preparing to go into schools
were mindfulness may or may not
be part of the curriculum.
DANIEL RECHTSCHAFFEN: Yeah,
thank you for the question.
So I just happened to grow up--
I grew up in a place called
the Omega Institute,
which is on the East
Coast is kind of like Esalen, if
you know Esalen down the coast.
It's kind of like a new age
meditation retreat center.
So I grew up with people
like gurus and shamans
and meditators all around.
And my parents though,
even though I lived there,
I was never once told to
meditate or to do yoga
or to do any of that.
I was just like a kid.
I could just do it.
And I actually
really like-- even
though I'm teaching
kids mindfulness
and I see the benefit of it,
especially with younger kids
and with parents, what
I really recommend
is what my experience
was with my upbringing,
is that I had an incredibly
empathic and attuned parents.
And if I became
a good person, it
was not because they told
me to focus and be nice.
It was because they were
nice and focused on me.
And that's the deepest--
that's the first thing
I say to teachers as well.
When I train
teachers, I always--
like I worked at a school in San
Francisco this whole last year.
The first four months I
only trained teachers.
I told them, don't do anything
with your kids different.
They all explained,
and this always
happens, that there was big
transformations with the kids.
And there's actually a
recent research study
that showed when elementary
school teachers are trained
in mindfulness,
their kids actually
act out less and have--
like the kids transform,
just because the
teachers are being nicer.
So for parents,
that's the practice,
is learning how to be present
with all of the stress
that having a young
child has, learning
how to work with
reactivity, and not--
basically the classic thing
of like all of the things
that your parents did but
you didn't want to do,
but you end up doing
anyways, because it's
so hard to be with those
emotions inside of ourselves.
Whew.
OK, let's break this
cycle and learn how to--
I'm very much of the opinion
that the words that we end up
saying to our kids are the
words that become the our kids'
inner voices, right?
So how are we showing up?
So it's just a big call
for our own practice,
our own emotional intelligence,
our own mindfulness practice.
With very young kids, once,
if you are really present,
there's some very fun games.
But they to be fun.
Like, you have a kid lay
down and put a little Teddy
bear on their belly.
And as they're
breathing in and out,
they feel it rising and falling.
Or M some fun kind of relaxation
games and little breathing
techniques and kind of
fun kind of yoga movement.
But yeah, I guess I'll end
the speech just by saying
that the practice is yours.
That's where the
huge transformation
comes in, is when
we take ownership
of our own inner world and
then become that inner world.
Thank you all so much
for all your time.
[APPLAUSE]